les informations du parisien il se
laisse dépasser un drame aujourd'hui
france 2 va supprimer une épreuve
emblématique de fort boyard l'épreuve
des cylindres c'est une épreuve lancée
en deux camps en 1993 elle a été joué
plus d'une centaine de fois mais
seulement une dizaine par des hommes
l'épreuve était d'ailleurs jugé un peu
sexiste et je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont enlevés regardez à quoi ça
ressemblait alors aujourd'hui je vous
dis ah j'aime j'aime pas c'est benjamin
contre gilles vous vous n'aimez pas
benjamin vous êtes scandalisé par cet
arrêté n'est pas d'or chez nous à la
rédaction je vous le dis ce matin tout
le monde était hyper v ner que cette
épreuve side et vous trouvez que c'est
une voleuse est vrai que c'est parti je
t'en fous des clés oui tu as du temps
chez les pros content il reste allongé
c'est à dire toutefois s'il ne quitte
jamais le cylindre
[Applaudissements]
cette histoire ça a été fou à la basse à
wasquehal et aldi gilbert dette vous
aimez vous trouvez que c'est normal
qu'ils suppriment bien sûr c'était une
épreuve sexiste c'est une bonne décision
il aurait fallu la prendre avant
réveillez-vous castaldi la france alors
changé de prime à la casse alors
franchement alors je sais pas et temps
qui courent il est de bon ton de prendre
des décisions etc
honnêtement cette épreuve elle est là
depuis ce n'est pas dix ans dans le fort
mais des ski alpin en quoi ces valses
avant encore wade n 5 en quoi c'est
choquant bon effectivement ces jolies
ces défis qui sont sur un rouleau quel
est le problème
l'axé principal il faut arrêter il faut
tennis france des défilés en robe de
chambre
il faut admettre les gens dans la boue
dans koh lanta mais confort est 7e et de
faire des combats de boue dans le fort
boyard aussi parce qu'elle est combo
entre femmes
non merci et s'il y avait une épreuve où
tout d'un coup on est tous les hommes
enfin laisse paraître la moitié de leurs
testicules savez moi y avait d'autres
options il suffisait aussi de filmer
différemment oui je suis d'accord avec
eux c'est vrai surtout d'accorder des
combinaisons il jouer là-dessus et c'est
vrai qu'ils filmaient comme ça on voyait
est la manière de filmer sauf sur une
épreuve et on voit un testicule un à
chaque fois les mêmes reste c'est à
peine si c'est vrai que c'est pas
agréable pour les fous comme je suis
d'accord vous le feriez s'avoue suis sûr
que non ben non je ne ferai pas moi même
et je mettrai en combiné semaine un
t-shirt remettre un tee shirt colmont
vous auriez vous kelly moi je suis
contente qu'on les supprime et parce que
je le fais dans deux semaines
et franchement oui je suis content enfin
parce que ça va aller me faire et
j'avais les boules avance bah ouais
qu'on voulait en soit c'est la tenue qui
choque plus
un tee shirt coloré mais chut c'est le
principe c'est benjamin castaldi contre
celle d'hermès donc alors des merci ça y
est ils ont dit sous couvert d'une
émission familiale on exhibait
honteusement la poitrine des le candidat
aujourd'hui
plus faire géraldine on peut pas soit
victimiser les femmes voilà les amis on
peut en tant que femme décidée que par
exemple mais on peut mettre un t-shirt
pour cette aimable et si l on compare
niati sharaman ou un débat est lancé
non j'étais en voyage je souhaite c'est
que je devais aller rouleau je devais me
foute un maillot demain j'ai fait ma
maison de plongée partant les rouleaux
je vais pas me mettre en bikini vous
aimez les rouleaux je vous le dis il
joue un peu mais quand même que sur ça
moi j'ai déjà vu le fort boyard trois
fois et l'approvisionnement des le faire
avec votre moitié justement j'y suis
allé parce qu'on vous pouvez tester des
épreuves on dormait à l'époque dans le
fort le soir et c'est une super épreuve
le problème c'est que c'est devenu un
bon sexy alors qu'à la base
pourquoi devez retirer il aurait juste
fallu et de faire faire par des garçons
parce que au niveau physique c'est très
difficile à faire et que ça les
intéresse pas et c'est devenu une
épreuve sexy que tu mets moi m'avait
demandé de faire fort boyard et j'ai
refusé à cause de cette séance justement
à cause de ces plans sur les phases sur
les seins et on m'a demandé il ya déjà
assez temps donc je trouve que sur une
chaîne de service public
il faut supprimer absolue faire vous
l'avez fait fort boyard ou pas non vous
avez envie de le faire non alors voilà
france 2 j'aime j'aime pas quand même
supprime avec benjamin castaldi que moi
si je vais faire on va pas me demander
de faire mais c'est génial